The idea behind professional development is that people have unused potential,...
...and that you need not limit yourself with what you have if you want to get more out of life.
It's a process of constantly advancing and perfecting yourself...
...and your qualities as a professional or individual.
Professional development and positive thinking are closely associated.
If you believe you can improve, then it's possible.
Looking at things in a positive way will give you more energy...
...and the strength to put more effort into everything because you are aiming at an end goal.
And setting realistic and achievable goals is at the center.
In order to know your progress,...
...you must have a timetable and be able to measure your goals.
This will give you a sense of achievement and reinforce your positive attitude.
Setbacks from the past or negative input from friends and family...
...can be a hindrance that you need to overcome.
Making changes and adhering to them are also not easy.
However, you need to stick to your plans.